Oh before this video begins however we
have a special offer announcement from
Origin PC they're running a December
only special with offers that include
free upgrade up to a two terabyte
Seagate sshd for PC bonus digital games
bonus digital games and more check out
nvidia geforce r-tx GPUs on Origin PC
desktops ooh where you can experience
certain pieces of games with lifelike
lighting shadows and reflections and if
you get one of these are tax disputes
you also get a free copy of battlefield
5 so you can see the ray-tracing
technology firsthand on your PC
ok that's epic also guys don't don't
forget about the newer on giveaway
that's going on if you haven't signed up
that yet I mean what the Frick are you
doing you get the same computer that I
have it's amazing I seriously love this
thing that all the same specs as me as
well and it's built with origin pcs
exclusive case which is really cool you
can tell the difference as well and you
can even customize your own designs on
these case it's really cool I know you
won't what are you doing go over to our
your PC and smash you like on this video
right frickin and the link to the
content is in description now let's keep
watching the video is it safe
hello fellow parents I'm here to address
your concerns
my name is beard upon and you can trust
me your kids are safe now tick tock why
are my kids miming to copyrighted
material I don't know but I think we can
all agree on is that tick tock has a
Nazi problem that's right everybody
tick tock which is mega popular with
children has a problem with blatant
violent words where where any mainstream
media are they trying to write an
article oh that's really interesting oh
this new thing is getting popular how
can we draw the connection with Nazism
so I'm here of course to address these
concerns for fellow parents to make sure
that your child's are
safe I also have this TV in the
background now I don't know for some
reason I thought hey that's a good idea
why not had copyrighted material in the
background that will make my life easier
but ever without further ado let's just
jump into it okay my love and affection
gee I wonder where he's gonna throw it
[Music]
that was a wholly funny case of that
dead space yep
that's someone getting love and
affection right there see this is what
I'm telling you parents
tick-tock it's completely safe there's
nothing to worry about
look at this just love and affection
being spread everywhere makes me happy
no God you know you know kids are gonna
start doing this through their patterns
now it's literally one tick tock gets
famous and everyone copies it what is
tick tock and why does my son keep
throwing to kill us at my face mom you
didn't do the right reaction he's
supposed to be in pain
all right let's keep jumping into it
guys what is this oh my god yeah we're
gonna have to cut this video gasp see
this is what I'm talking about it's so
nice with talented young artists on tik
tok finally getting recognition makes me
happy it makes me warm
it makes me I can't even no no I refuse
hey guys it's my first day living in the
hood sup yo it's my first week living in
hood I've been in this [ __ ] for about a
month now [ __ ] you mean dick hey we've
been in this [ __ ] for about two months
now two weeks since me actually hurt my
throat Jesus
sorry neighbors Oh is he gonna do it boo
damn that was sexy that's some sexy
quality Oh a Trinity Wow please please I
thought it was real because at the at
this one it bounces up the top right
because I've seen ones that cheat and
they why do I care you know what it
doesn't matter
hey proud to say that I'm a
granddaughter of a world war two vet as
well as the needs of a correctional
officer however people on this app
pretending to be like whatever military
branch or Special Forces or FBI or
whatever have to knock it off this is
why the United States is screwed
everybody cuz everyone be doing for
tonight dances
okay this is one of those okay what's it
gonna be I mean no oh god damn it
never mind actually this does not help
the case at all that I was trying to
make okay
it's a twin
[Music]
that's kind of cool I guess see it's
just people having fun guys
there's no Nazi tick-tock 3 128 okay
hahaha no no no no no no close if you're
white if you're black if you're trans if
you're gay if you're lesbian it's okay
cuz everybody has something in common
and what we have in common we don't
think is funny she that's right
everybody that's right everybody but
she's still in rewind still in rewind
top ten scientists still can't figure it
it out and I used to spend so much time
like focus and thinking about him and
not me the minute that I stopped and I
was like you know I don't need a guy
that's when I peaked in my career our
career peaked everybody who at this
point who's doing tick tocks own
ironically because we all have ironic
tic TOCs and then reacting to ironic tic
TOCs but I feel like at some point it's
gonna be an ironic ironic tick tock
really reacting to I wrote you know I
that's already happening over my kids
who's it gonna be who's it gonna be
[Laughter]
[Music]
I'd like this and I swear I don't even
remember watching it what's wrong with
me Yatta boy fact that it doesn't yes
yeah
don't let your - yeah hey Jordan message
at Eliza
I'm so disappointed I'm Isis
well good thing this isn't your life you
lose look at my health bar it's
completely fine it's fine I'm doing fine
by the way you guys I'm doing great
so people have really been calling me
homophobic so listen this is my house
right here I am opening the door and
walking in this [ __ ] all right so if
I'm homophobic then why the hell would I
walk into my home yo yo you can't argue
with facts and logic you cannot argue
with facts and logic goddamn hey it's
her again
I mean I sorta got at this point you're
better off making an ironic tick-tock
which secretly ironic cuz you know
everyone's gonna take that fate you know
if you open yourself up to get bullied
everyone's gonna do it and you'll get
tick tock famous for all the wrong
reasons
[Music]
I think dick talk is one with famous
things that happened this year on
ironically you know when you first saw
it you were like goddammit not another
thing like I cannot have another thing
like this in 2018 blessing in disguise
everybody blessing in disguise I send
that enforcer there wow there was a lot
of fun I think we proved our point today
then tick tock is a Nazi and that's
really the main point of this video hope
you guys enjoyed smash like if you
enjoyed and make sure that you enjoyed
and everyone tweet this video to James
Charles and he's just gonna be like what
the f dude can you imagine James Charles
reaction like watching this oh my god
I'm freaking out
you want pyramids we got him oh you're
into castles huh we got you covered baby
you want some bets easy we got it all
this game is still relevant god damn it